那主老師因為現在資金好像太氾濫了
所以以前我還記得在做股票的時候
說台股1000多億
2000億就是爆大量
可是現在動輒就是3000億是正常
4000億好像也不太能算爆大量了
沒錯我們現在的成交量大概3700億
平均嗎
平均5日的均量3700億
但如果你超過4000的話
基本上就算爆大量了
所以現在4000算爆大量
我會不會看到5000啊
會 會會會
因為這跟物價上漲通貨膨脹一樣
是
你不能把20年前的量
跟現在來比
因為現在資金比以前要多多了
幾乎進入股市的人也多
開戶的人也多
所以它當然成交量就會增加
未來我們今年的量大概4000億也會常常看到
因為你要過高一定要供過4000億
我們上面已經幾個頭都是4000億
所以都會超過4000億 甚至於5000億
因為現在量能非常的強勁
所以量要怎麼解讀就變得很重要
可能現在大量跟以前我們以為的大量也不一樣
量是一個相對來比較的
它不是絕對的
不是說2000就是一個天花板
一定他是一個相對的
所以我們今天特別來跟大家討論成交量
好 歡迎收看今天的標股在線等
大家最歡迎的朱家宏老師
今天的題目非常的重要就是成交量
因為剛剛我們就有聊到
現在的大量成為常態
平均量是3700億
所以很多股票你可能看到他的大量
跟以前你定義的大量已經完全不一樣了
再來你可能會有一個疑惑
有人會說 爆大量被套牢不好
有人說爆大量上功很好
有的人說 亮縮呢 下跌很好
有人說 亮縮下跌不好
到底為什麼同樣一個量
會有那麼多種解讀
我們先來看一下喔
常常看到這三個字啊
成交量 是不是真的懂喔
例如說 你看喔
台股俱正報53391天量
這個就是上市加上櫃啦
我們常常比較常講是上市的量
好 爆天亮
爆天亮到底好不好
有人會覺得說
爆天亮當然不好啊
大家都賣出來了
可是可能過了幾天
就發現說
欸 爆出來的亮
都有人接走了
他叫做換手亮
欸 怎麼解讀
好難喔
然後例如說
爆天亮要怕嗎
指數擊殺 灌破萬五
分析師說小心出貨
這應該是舊穩
因為灌破萬五
買啊 現在都已經萬六了
對
所以到底成交量
要怎麼去解讀
那成交量大家比較容易迷惑
就是大家對成交量有幾個
有幾個貫念沒有弄清楚
那我們在這邊討論一下
第一個剛才趙華也有講
爆大量到底是被人家買走了換手量
還是主力出貨
對
所以基本上我們要知道今天爆個量
是有人買有人買
不然就不會成交
就不會成交嘛
所以基本上今天成交量
是買進跟賣出的數量是一樣的
那既然是一樣的到底是
誰在買 誰在賣
對 重點就是後面是誰在買
誰在賣 才比較重要
所以第一個我們剛才主持人也有講說
爆大量也會漲
可是沒有爆量也會漲
對 而且有時候上工跟我說要爆量
不然這個漲得很虛
我就還滿頭不跑
所以我們市場上有兩派
技術分析上有兩派
有一派講說有量才有價
因為有人追買
那個價就會被追上來
可是另外一派講的剛好相反
有價才有量
如果你價不漲沒有人去追
因為你價漲才會引來追
所以主力要拉股票會連拉三天
然後不請自來
散戶不請自來
那為什麼 那是因為你有價
你的價漲了 所以散戶都來追
所以聽起來兩個都有道理
那實際上這兩個在我們食物上
是都會發生的
有量會代價
那同樣有價也會代量
因此陳教亮才會讓人家摸不清楚
這是第一個
那等一下我們會討論
那第二個就是
陳教亮當然他是代表籌碼
尤其是股票個股
因為個股的這個籌碼是固定的
他不是無限的對不對
所以他當然代表這個籌碼是換手了
還是有人接走還是有人去出貨
第三個最重要的是這個
我們不能只看成交量
就決定它是進貨還是出貨
你光看量是沒有辦法決定的
所以你一定要配合我們這四個關鍵
各位以後你看到量
再加上這四個大概八九不離十了
量跟價的關係有四個關鍵點
第一個當然是趨勢
你看到是多頭的量還是空頭的量
是空頭下跌殺出的量
還是多頭上漲的攻擊量
所以第一個當然你要看
在什麼趨勢你的量
那這兩個趨勢都會有爆量
都會出大量
所以這邊老師的趨勢是多頭
就是我們之前講的頭頭高
低低高 對不對
空頭是頭頭低低低低
你今天看的一個成交量
是在多頭還是空頭
那第二個是位置
那我們的位置分很多
如果在多頭就有起漲的位置
高檔的位置 壓力的位置
回檔支撐的位置
那這幾個重要的位置
再加上有量
你大概研判就差不多了
所以第二個一定要配合位置
就像趙花剛剛講
有人說爆大量買 結果被套牢
有人爆大量買 結果他漲了
噴上去
所以最重要是位置
你爆大量買 再高檔了
所以他就容易被套牢
你如果是起漲 爆大量你就容易漲
所以這個第二個是位置
那第三個當天股價漲還是跌
你爆了一個大量是跌了5%還是漲5%
這差很多
如果是跌5%
那表示今天
我們剛剛有講
今天有假設成交1萬張
是不是有一萬張賣出
有一萬張是買進
那這一萬張賣出
我們就叫做賣的力量
那買進就是接的
多方接手的力量
那這兩個力量到底誰強呢
反應在股價
強的就會
例如說買的強就會漲
如果今天成交一萬張是漲了五趴
那這個就很厲害了
追漲的意願很強
買盤的力量強
那如果今天成交一萬張是跌五趴
那就是賣的力量強
所以第一個就要看
我看到大量還要看
今天是漲還是跌
那最後就是明天
其實明天才最重要
因為今天已經結束了
所以買誰賣
我們可能可以查出來了
外資賣的 融資買的
你可以查到這些籌碼
但是第二天不一定
外資賣有時候第二天會漲的
是
對不對
因為很奇妙
有時候有的股票
內資做得比外資還厲害
沒錯 你說台積電賣
現在不是前兩天都在漲
對不對
所以你就會搞糊塗了
這個到底怎麼辦
所以最重要就是最後一個
看明後天的股價
因為股價就決定成交量是誰買誰賣的
所以我們基本上我個人的觀念
成交量是事後論
就像剛剛講說換手量
你怎麼知道說換手
那是因為大量以後它漲了
所以這個就變換手
對就變換手
那如果大量跌了
你就不會就變出貨量
所以成交量一個很簡單
它就是一個第二天來論
第二天你是漲還是跌
然後你的位置你的趨勢
你這四樣東西都照顧到了
你的成交量就可以研判
而且他也可以告訴你
你這個地方是要該走了
該賣了
因為你爆大量股價不漲
你是不是要賣
對
人家都賣了
所以我們決定都是隔天再決定
隔天再決定來得及嗎
因為你當天大量藏紅
是不是當天買的力道很強
是
那結果你爆了大量力道這麼強
結果第二天股價不漲
開跌
跌
那這個問題你叫小準備
這樣OK嗎
好 那我們還是一樣
我們來看一下我們的量價關係
那我們剛剛有講量跟價
它的這個變化不是絕對的
它會跟位置跟趨勢有關
那我們在這張圖上就知道
這邊是多 這邊是空
那我們就要來看多頭裡面的一些
位置跟量價的關係
那這邊有旗漲對不對
這邊盤整的突破
所以你會看到有量有價
有大量又有價
那這裡是回後上漲
他也是有量有價
但是第二天注意下股價不要下跌
第二天股價不要下跌
股價下跌他就容易回蕩
所以像這種現象就容易是一個假突破
我們經常會碰到假突破
假突破他也是會有量的
有量有價才會騙人進去
才會覺得是突破
對
那結果他股價不漲
你就要趕快提高警覺
這個就叫做不正常
我們一般來說
在旗長有量有價就是要供
如果不供就要注意
不供就可能是假的
那這個有供
那這個也是一樣
回後上漲
有量有價然後有供
那這個就很好
他又在旗長位置
那我們再來看在高檔
高檔又出了大量
要小心了
股價不漲就會回到
我爆了大量
結果第二天股價是下跌的
就特別的要注意
好那現在趨勢沒有改喔
這只是回檔嘛
對
對 回檔以後你看他又攻了
他是不是紅K又上漲
可是這個架是平的
就是說架並沒有很突
他攻的這個量是
對
其實應該很低吧
跟五日軍量是很接近的
也就是說沒有很大的攻擊量
那這個樣子的股票
就是第二天他要能夠繼續的放量
第二天要拉亮出來
對
那現在已經一天兩天三天
這在高檔了
高檔的大量長紅
股價今天是上漲
第二天就不能跌了
因為你在高檔
所以高檔你爆亮
結果第二天是大量黑K
股價下跌
因為第二天這個黑K量也很大
但是它的股價卻是下跌的
你又在高檔
所以它當然就很容易殺下來
後面我們就轉成空頭了
在空頭裡面
我們也會去看
這個是亮縮的黑K
也就是說這跟黑K亮是縮的
但是還是會疊
老師為什麼亮縮黑K
大家都會講說
在空頭裡面
對 在空頭裡面我解釋一下
基本上成交量跟股價
沒有太大的關係
空頭比較不看亮
為什麼 因為空頭主力
已經賣掉了
所以有亮也會疊 沒亮也會疊
所以空頭裡面
我們看趨勢跟位置
只要這個位置是空
它就會下來 有亮也可以空
沒亮也可以空
這個空頭裡面最大的一個
跟成交量的關係
所以在空頭裡面
你很成交量 經常也看不懂的
所以我們就以趨勢為主
它是一個空
你看彈後空下跌嘛
這就是這個
那這個有亮
當然OK它就會跌
但是這兩個彈後空
彈後空這兩個都沒有亮
這個亮都是縮的
但是它還是一樣會跌
因為它就是空頭
它是一個空頭趨勢
所以我們一直在講說
基本上趨勢最重要
趨勢跟位置
你做多一定要再多投
那你要進場要再起漲
你不要再高檔買
那有時候高檔也會沒量
它也是會疊
那就叫價量倍理
價量倍理
它也是會疊
我們在後面在這個容要班就會講
常說報大量報大量
到底多少的量
我們可以把它定義成報大量
我們剛才一直在講大量大量
那我們有一個比較有一個規則
你才容易抓這個到底有沒有爆料
對不對
我們一般來說有一個基本量
它就是五天的平均量
剛才講我們的大盤
3700億
就是五天的平均
因為它有時候亮到3300
有時候又爆到4000
可是這五天來
這個平均量就作為我們的基本量
就是說你能夠維持這樣
就表示這個量還可以維持住
比如說五天均量3700
就是你如果有3600
即都維持的基本量
可是如果你量今天放大了
比五日均量大了1.2到1.3倍
那今天就開始放量了
比如說昨天一萬張
平均五日均量一萬張
今天出了一萬三千張
那就表示今天放量了
也就是比昨天買的人多了三成
對不對 那這個就放大量
那我們剛剛講高檔不要爆量
對 爆量跟放量不一樣
這爆量就是兩倍以上了
昨天五日均量一萬 今天兩萬
那甚至於三萬
是
那就越大就越恐怖嘛
對不對
那個量我們常常講叫做101大樓
是
那個特別
突然一根跑上去這樣
那你就要特別小心
所以量它基本上
它是根據五日均量去做比較的
那如果你每天都在平均放量
那五日均量就會越來越多
對不對
你五天的量越來越大
它的均量就會大
所以我們是根據五日均量去做比較的
這是我們一般技術分析上量的比較的
那我個人的經驗是跟昨天來比的
跟昨天來比
昨天的量
為什麼因為假設多頭回檔量不是會縮嗎
那今天為什麼會放了1.5倍 1.3倍
那就今天有人來買了
然後剛才有講
有了量還要看什麼
還要看價
價的位置
我今天有多了1.3倍
那價有沒有上來
如果1.3倍價是黑的
往下跌那就不好了
那還會再跌
那如果價上來了
就又說我們可以起漲的位置
那表示今天有供給量
所以我的供給量
要比昨天或者五日均量
要大一點3倍
你才有供給的量
那我們在成交量有講
因為做多
所以旗長最好是有大量
雖然沒有量也會漲
那沒有量要漲就是注意第二天
第二天可以補量
我們常常聽句話可以補量
我今天的量也許平平的
並沒有放
可是我明天可以開高走高放量
所以明天開盤你就注意一下
它的預估量
如果明天的預估量
爆了 爆出來了
那就表示會攻了
還是會繼續攻
所以我們的量在大致上
上漲有量總是比較有力嘛 對不對
或是有量然後伴隨是上漲
不是下跌
顧家下上漲
所以我這裡有兩個口訣
口訣大家就平常這樣子練一練
低檔爆大量
不是 朱老師你知道老王也有這兩個口訣
老王也是喜歡用口訣
但是我們來記朱老師的口訣
各有各的口訣
我們一般來說低檔爆大量
低檔爆大量
因為低檔有兩種情形
一個是空頭一直疊的低檔
對不對
那這時候爆亮
第二天我剛剛講
第二天股價不疊
是紅的
我們剛剛看了好多
一個常可以就拇指懷抱
就紅的
那這時候它就要反彈
因為你在空頭
低檔爆大量
隔天股價是紅的
紅的它就要反彈
那如果在多頭
什麼叫低檔
就是回檔
回檔之後
回檔了兩三天
報個量結果股價不跌
大概就要漲了
所以你去注意一下
總之在第一檔報大量
也就是說
有人很多人賣
在第一檔很恐慌
那可是有人買走了
那你怎麼知道買走的人是比較厲害
還是賣的人比較厲害
那就是看第二天
第二天如果股價不跌
他就反彈
那相反的高檔報大量
高檔報大量
股價不漲就要回檔
已經報量了還公布上去
高檔對這麼多人買
結果第二天居然股價不漲
你就要小心
大概應該是出貨的力量比較強
所以他就容易回檔
所以爆量
就在兩個位置最重要一個在高檔
一個在低檔
如果在低檔爆量基本上
比較容易往上走
就有人接嘛
我們講高檔爆量就有人賣嘛
所以他就比較容易跌
所以如果高檔爆量之後是蓄功那也還好
那就叫換手成功
所以我們講股價高檔爆量股價不漲
對 才會跌嘛
漲就沒問題啦
如果連三天都爆量 連三天都漲
那就我就繼續爆嘛
可是第四天要是不漲就要小心了
它就很容易跌
所以我們簡單的這樣去計
你大概成交量就可以抓到了
就可以抓到
好 那我們剛才
實際例子來看
對 我們就要來計例子
這是盤整突破多頭確認的爆大量
所以這個很好
這是平地一生雷
對
這個很像101大龍
對不對
所以這個地方就表示多頭確認
然後再來
這個地方又經過盤整的確認
然後爆
這個都叫爆量
都是昨天的兩倍
對
當然也都是十日均量的兩倍
這條紅的線就是五日均量
藍的線就是十日均量
是
所以你今天一下子就爆了兩三倍了
所以這個地方就容易攻
就容易攻
這個地方我們看爆亮的地方
最近有爆亮 有爆亮 有爆亮
這三個都有爆亮
這個位置是盤整的第一根
所以它容易攻
現在這一根的位置就在高檔
然後黑K呢
沿著五軍在高檔
居然是黑K
所以當然它就容易回檔或者是容易盤整
所以這個地方是一個盤整盤
K線的盤整
在這裡給我們剛剛有講
如果爆大量股價漲
就是換手
所以這一根
紅K上漲就是這一根大量
怎麼樣被突破
這根大量被突破
就是換手成功
所以後續還要再漲
還會再漲
在這個地方我們又看到了
爆大量
那這根爆量是很好
對不對 是換手成功
那這根爆量是黑K
又一個長黑K
所以骨架就會疊
而且留一個上影線
而且我們一直到現在
趨勢沒有改
趨勢還是多頭
這時候回後上漲
它又有這個叫放量
還不叫爆亮
沒有兩倍
這跟紅K爆大量
超級大量
一倍兩倍三倍
三倍第二天骨架不長
手也跟大黑K
骨架就要疊了
所以它就很容易有回落
爆那麼大的量隔天不長
在這裡我們就來講
你知道在高檔爆量 股價就容易回檔
那回檔就看你的紀律了
你當初在做的時候 你是做什麼的
做短 還是做長 還是做短
假設你做短 第二天股價不漲
所以跌破五均 你就要賣
就要賣了
如果你做中 跌破十均 你就要賣
如果你做長 跌破月線 你就賣
也該賣了
也不至於跌到這了
對
因為你這裡已經有告訴你要回檔的訊號
高檔爆量 主價不漲
就要回檔囉
那就看你自己怎麼決定
因為賣股票跟買股票都是你決定的
你要去追高也是你決定的
你要去賣低也是你決定的
但是技術分析會告訴你訊號
再來看一檔
因為剛才趙華的疑問就是那到底什麼時候買
像剛剛中當我一看我以為可以買
可是就盤了好幾個月
那個就是我們以後講操作
因為你操作就要配合均線跟支撐壓力
如果你壓力太重的話就不適合去買
那當然這是底部爆亮
那這是多頭確認
那你看這個多頭確認是不是也有回來
還有回來啊
也就告訴你這一定有個季線
因為這個月線才剛上來嘛
所以季線應該還在這
那現在回後上漲這邊可能就上季線
那因為季線再經過一段時間就會走平了嘛
那這個跳空大量就上季線
那上季線以後這個地方就開始漲了
那走到這個地方你又看
哇 又一個大量
超級大量 這是黑的喔
所以你股價不漲
這跟黑的沒有過之前
它這個上影線都是壓
因為你出了大量 沒有漲
當天就是流了上影線
就表示這個地方一定有壓的
可是這個壓要是被突破了
被大量突破了
那這個地方就變成換手成功
他換手啦
但是為什麼這樣講
因為你趨勢沒有改
這個地方是盤整
所以趨勢沒有改
他只是長不動
他只是爆了大量在這邊
一直洗盤
洗到最後爆亮突破
他就會漲了
但是在這邊買的人就很壓力了
對 很壓力
但是你也沒有賠什麼啦
因為我們一直
怎麼我買了就不漲
常有這種心情
因為我們一直跟他講
你要收盤確認
第一個你收盤確認是一個大量廠商一些
所以基本上你不是在這買的
因為我們上課都講過
買要買紅K不能買黑K
尤其是大量的黑K
大量黑K就是壓力很重
所以你要特別注意
假設你買了你也知道這是一個多頭
只要它趨勢
多頭的前低在這
只要前低沒有破多頭都沒有改變
所以這邊叫盤整
那盤整突破當然就可以繼續
所以我們講操作來說
你完全按機率
那你跌破五均賣
所以你沒有什麼要賠
那跌破五均以後
那這個地方是盤整
所以你要等盤整突破
假設你在這裡買
其實這裡已經是盤整
因為你這個高點沒過
你在這裡買
你手停損
你是沒有賠錢的
你是賺錢的
你是賺錢
其實這邊買
其實就差不多是在等了
對 如果你在
因為你月線還在向上
你還在月線上
而且你今天也是有量的
對 也是有一個大量
假設你在這裡買
那這個可以加碼了
因為你成功了
你買了結果壓力過了
因為我在這買我也知道這是壓壓
因為這個壓一直都沒過
所以我出了大量的長上引線
各位都可以養一個習慣
就花一條壓力線
我後面看你過不過
過不過
過了再加碼
過了就加碼
因為過了它就轉牆
沒有過 甚至於轉空你就趕快跑
轉成空頭就要跑
第一是看隔日有沒有表態
第二就是看畫一條壓力線
有沒有過那個壓力線
第三個回來有沒有把趨勢改變
有沒有把前低跌破
如果沒有都還在維持一個多頭
它只是可能爆了量要洗一下
要洗一洗
那這時候你等到後面有機會的話
很容易獲利 好不好
好 那接下來我們會講
剛才有講了嘛
爆量有時候上功
爆量有時候下跌
有時候量縮是上功
所以基本上我們量價有幾種關係
第一個就是我們講量
量增價漲 對不對
量增價漲
第二個 量增價跌
第三個 量縮上漲
我們基本上有九種關係
九種關係嗎
很簡單 為什麼
因為
還有平
因為量有三種嘛
漲縮跟平嘛
那價有三種嘛
所以這三個乘三就變九種
那有一些量價關係並沒有那麼重要
比如說又沒量又沒價
也沒什麼好看的就這邊
所以我們大概有四種量價比較重要
就是平的我們先不說啦
我們就是漲跌
我們來看一下
漲跌跟量的增減
那這一段呢叫價漲量增
這個價在漲量的一直在增加
那這個增加當然是跟前面去做比較
他也沒有爆量
這個沒有兩倍嘛
所以這個其實價漲量增還算是蠻
他有點穩定放單
蠻穩定的配合
好那再來這一段有爆大量
真有爆大量囉
所以這你就不漲了
那這你就盤
盤了以後價又開始繼續漲
可是我發現量卻沒有
量沒有這麼大了
你越漲到上面量越來再縮
這個叫價漲量縮
價漲量縮也叫價量背離
那代表意識
我股價意識漲好像追買的力量
沒有那麼強
不像說我價漲大家都來追
怎麼大家都不追了
那可能這個地方股價就容易跌了
價漲量說價量背離
本來就是股價容易跌
那現在開始價跌了
量也說了
這個其實說起來是好的
價跌量說就賣壓不重
價跌量說就是剛剛趙華講的
好像大家習受
大家都不賣
太便宜我不賣
可是如果你價一跌量又開始增了
那就賣的人開始恐慌
賣壓出籠了
那不要忘了我們剛剛講的位置
你又跌得很深了
你這邊跌得很深
然後開始有量了
你這邊有出量了
這叫低檔爆量
低檔爆量股價不跌
甚至上漲就會反彈了
它就會反彈
剛才的秘訣
低檔爆大量股價不跌
這個紅K當然是不跌
它就容易反彈
這個是空頭的反彈
這樣我們大概會有這四種狀況
這四種狀況我們就要看位置
好
價漲量增如果在盤整突破
對
在回後上漲
那就可以買
買進
因為他量也來了
價也漲了
價
這個
如果價漲量增
這個量價在高檔
對
我又有價量又
結果不再創高
不再創高了
那就是股價不漲
是
主力在出貨
那這時候我們就要賣
如果你的價漲量增在高檔
是
那剛才口訣不要忘了
高檔大量
股價要漲
股價不創高
要跌就主力就會出貨
好
那我們來看價漲量縮的
如果在剛開始可能只是反彈
如果價漲量沒有跟上
所以只是反彈
然後上漲的行徑
股價就容易飆漲
這個代表習受
如果他在漲
量卻一直縮
但是股價卻一直漲
那這個大概就標股
對耶 很多標股
不然你買不到啊
好 我們剛剛講的前面兩個
我們現在看第三個狀況
就是價跌 但是量卻增加了
那在高檔 你就很容易下跌了
對不對
因為價已經跌了嘛
那你又量就表示賣壓出來了
基本上大概就是把它先當做賣壓
賣壓有很多種
短線獲利的
還有前面壓力解套的
這個量就跑出來
可是你股價是跌的
所以如果你是多頭
你又有獲利
你是不是也要準備
跟著一樣要停利了
那如果在第一檔就很容易反彈
我們剛才不是講到口訣嗎
對不對 第一檔爆量
但是股價如果不跌
不跌了 它就會彈
那這個如果你有空單的
是不是就要考慮明天
不跌就要回補
最後一個是價也跌量也縮
又沒價又沒量
那我們就看位置
如果是上升段的行徑
那就是正常的回檔
為什麼 因為這是多頭的回檔
一跌就縮
你價又跌就沒有量了
就表示沒有人要賣
那就很好
也就要準備再來買了
如果他不跌又上漲的話
盤整的區間
當然又沒價沒量
你也不要隨便進去
也不要去猜有沒有這個地方是低檔去買
或高檔去買
就等到他後來去表態
比如說他盤枕突破又亮了
駕掌亮針盤枕突破
那當然就很好
你就可以進場
那如果說是一個空頭下跌了
我們的出跌主跌當然就只在空頭裡面
空頭有三個波段嘛 對不對
那如果在剛剛開始跌主跌
不要隨便做多或拆底
因為它還沒有量
它量還是縮的
表示這個疊還不知道會不會止足
有一句話叫無量下疊
就無量下疊
沒有人來買股價不會漲
那末疊段就要看這個量說到什麼程度
那我們在這裡有一個叫做智喜量
如果你疊到有支撐的地方
又出現智喜量
智喜量在這邊也可以給大家一個標準
就是五日均量的二分之一
五日均量的二分之一
對 昨天一千張 今天只剩五百張了
那這個時候就要看價有沒有漲
如果出現自己量又第二天紅的
股價上漲 那這個地方就容易落底
落底跟紙疊不一樣
落底就是後面就不容易再破這個地點
它就會落在這裡
搞懂四種的量價關係了
我們實際找舉例來看好不好
它是不是真的符合
好
有沒有那麼神奇
我們看股票比較容易了解
我們剛剛說趨勢
如果這是多頭股票
那今天是不是駕漲量增
駕漲量增
那他又在洗漲
所以這個地方
隔天是漲的
對 他就很容易上漲
那這裡是回後買上漲
駕漲量增
再供一波
這是盤整突破的駕漲量增
所以在我們多頭進場兩個位置
一個回後上漲 一個盤枕突破
那這個兩個位置
如果是駕漲 亮針 骨架就容易上漲
那我們現在看到高檔
今天又來了
這個可是亮針 爆大亮而已
但是駕是疊的
為什麼 因為這個亮是綠色的
綠色亮都代表今天是下疊的
那今天的亮針但是駕是疊的
所以它明後天就容易回檔
當然位置也在高檔
它不是我們旗漲
那這個地方又是我們的旗掌
駕掌亮針在這個地方
所以它又很容易上漲
駕掌亮針
所以也是駕掌亮針
隔天又漲就繼續漲
駕掌亮針這個地方都容易漲
這高檔出現了駕碟亮針
這個地方的補駕收盤是疊的
所以它亮又增加
那這個地方就
亮在這裡
這個亮在這個地方
那這個地方就容易下跌
那第二天我們就看第二天
所以第二天他確認下跌
所以當然會回到
那這個地方就不一樣了
為什麼
因為這個黑K是空頭確認
所以你變空頭了
結果股價跌
量又增
所以當然這個地方的量增
這個是不是爆量
它就是稍微放大了
就1.2%大概2成的
放量
所以這邊價跌量增
那趨勢又轉空
所以這個就很容易往下跌
所以我們大概你看到的這幾種關係
再加上趨勢跟位置
一大致這樣都容易判別
我們可以再舉一檔看一下
好 我們再來看一下
那我們今天是不是看到爆一個大量
這叫爆大量
所以昨天的兩倍了
或者武軍的兩倍
可是你的架是疊的
因為又是一個可以流上一些
那架就架沒有長嘛 對不對
那這時候你比較小心
你這個地方又流了一個大量在這
所以它又變壓力
所以它還是很容易下來
那下來這邊是盤整
這邊就進到盤整
那盤整的突破價漲量增
這樣對不對
上工了
那第二天價也是漲的喔
因為還是紅的
是量增
再來今天的價
價漲量縮
這個量縮下來
那這一段我們就叫價量背離了
喔 價漲量縮了
沒錯 你看我的大量是不是還看到高點
還看到高點 量沒有再過高
那這時候骨架一疊就容易回蕩
骨架疊 那今天架疊量縮 量縮下來了對不對
那我們剛剛有講 下疊成交量說不說
長不長都一樣 他都會疊
所以我們一直告訴大家一個觀念
我們在操作的時候 停利剩你的紀律
是 實際上停利跟成交量沒關
我跌破五均我就賣了
所以你有量沒量都要賣
都要賣 都要賣
可是你進場的話你可以配合成交量
因為我進場希望成功率高嘛
對不對 所以我如果做多
進場價漲量增
那對我們是有利的
所以我一直強調股價來決定這個量
那第二個就是位置
你大概這幾個重點抓到
應該這個量價關係就能夠配合得很好
好
剛剛朱老師一直有講到量價背離
而且很多的標股還是量價背離
所以到底怎麼來看量價背離
就要請你進入到我們的榮耀班
請你加入我們的榮耀班
會仔細的教你量價背離抓標股
剛剛朱老師耳聽面面
成交量是訊號
你看到爆大量你提高你的警覺
但是隔天的股價才是你自身的關鍵
如果隔天股價繼續漲
沒有跌破你手的紀律
不管是手5日手10日甚至手月線
你就按照紀律來操作
但是爆亮就是給你一個提醒
你不要爆亮了你隔天都不理他
因為他可能就要提醒你
隔天一起會下跌
隔天可能要出場
所以爆亮這件事情
請把他當作一個很重要的訊號
那希望今天的成交量教學
對你的投資有幫助囉
我們下次再見了
拜拜
字幕製作人Zither Harp